c'est non
[Musique]
théoriquement planté le goût de la ddte
poussé par les embruns labeyrie goulaine
à berry goulaine tempo licha
labeyrie goulaine viêt lutter jour le
retour du marin parti naguère guerroyer
le hareng à bord du trois-mâts le remous
mais leur moutarde et la burie goulaine
s'étiole je m'étiole le jour ça va
encore je compte les mouettes
mais à partir de 20h30 je peux dire que
je m'étiole
berry goulaine bérigaud l'un ne vous
étiez les plus
la minute nécessaire de monsieur
cyclopède va revenir tous les soirs à
20h30 sur une chaîne de télévision dont
je tairai le nom pour ne pas faire de
publicité à fr3
maintenant que monsieur cyclopède est de
retour je peux dire que je me forme à
coiffe
etonnant non
[Musique]
comment reconnaître un vrai jumeau d'un
faux jumeaux me demande madame miro de
colombey les deux ovules et bien c'est
très simple regardez
voici un homme très triste
son frère jumeau la quitter il ne
supporte pas la séparation
aïe
c'est donc un vrai jumeau car seul un
vrais jumeaux ne supporte pas d'être
séparé de son frère
et maintenant j'accuse cet homme d'être
un faux jumeaux bon oeil non de type
oled ne me quitte pas eh bien oui vous
avez compris cet homme est un faux
jumeaux car comme nous le dit pythagore
un faux jumeaux supporte d'être séparé
de son frère mais pas de sa tatie
paulette
damned je suis fait
étonnant non
[Musique]
m
à la guerre il est très important de
reconnaître l'ennemi car sans ennemi la
guerre est ridicule
comment reconnaître l'ennemi c'est
simple regardez bien
comme vous le voyez l'ennemi a des
oreilles il n'est pas contagieux mais il
est héréditaire
il est so il croit que c'est nous
l'ennemi alors que c'est lui et c'est
lui qui le dit qu'il y eu
quelquefois l'ennemi essaie de se
déguiser en géraniums c'est le cas ici
mais on ne peut pas s'y tromper tandis
que le géranium est à nos fenêtres
l'ennemi est à nos portes je suis fait
étonnant non
[Musique]
une poignée de boutonneux passionné de
mycologie ne demandent comment
reconnaître un centaure d'un percheron
c'est simple comme nous le raconte omar
sharif dans liliane le centaure est un
monstre moitié cochon moitié poisson
alors que le percheron est un animal me
home mi cheval
j'ai près de moi un magnifique percheron
comme vous le voyez la robe est gris
pommelé la croupe nerveuse et l'air con
j'ai l'air con le percheron est le fruit
monstrueux d'une idylle contre nature
entre un maréchal ferrant et une jument
de mauvaise vie la honte mans pourpre
c'est vrai toujours est il que plus
aucun doute n'est permis
c'est en forgeant qu'on devient
percheron
est ou non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
superman est il un vrai français
voilà une question intelligente
et qu'on ne peut pas s'empêcher de se
poser quand on sait que superman ne
sauve pratiquement jamais personne le
jour de la pâque russe quoi qu'il en
soit pour savoir si superman est
français ou non le plus simple d'aller
demander à sa grand mère
je me trouve chez super mamie est super
papy les grands-parents de superman
à première vue ils ont l'air
parfaitement français
mais cela reste à prouver
regardez bien on y va tapez 1 on y va
maman
bien oui vous avez compris super mamie
est super papy sont bretons en effet ils
ont des chapeaux ronds vive la bretagne
ils ont des chapeaux ronds vive les
bretons ils ont des chapeaux ronds vive
les bretons
etonnant non
[Musique]
nous voulons plus la face la troisième
guerre mondiale est inéluctable
il ne nous reste plus beaucoup de temps
pour rigoler
alors dépêchons nous nous avons joué à
un jeu très amusant nous allons jouer au
rébus vivant regardez bien
[Applaudissements]
cette somme doit irrésistiblement vous
évoquez le titre d'une vieille chanson
française
non
bien alors regardez voilà qui va vous
aider je suis le petit patapon je suis
un empereur romain très méchant je garde
les moutons eh bien oui vous avez
compris le titre de la chanson était il
était une bergère il était une bergère
iran et roux petit patapon il était une
bergère néron héron petit patapon il
était une bergère qui gardait ses
moutons d'entre eux qui garder ses
moutons qui tenant non
[Musique]
une brassée de soudou est irrécupérable
me demande aimablement à quel moment il
faut rire quand on assiste à une pièce
de théâtre eh bien chers amis minable
c'est très simple pour ne pas être
ridicules au théâtre il suffit de savoir
reconnaître au premier coup d'oeil une
pièce tragique d'une pièce comique
comment c'est simple regardez bien
vous regardez bien
to be or not to be
la thèse de quoi eh bien oui vous avez
compris dans une pièce comique l'amant
est dans le placard dans une pièce
tragique la mort et sur le placard
non
on peut difficilement s'empêcher de
penser que si napoléon avait vécu 90 ans
de plus
il aurait très bien connues louis
armstrong
moi j'en un problème monsieur napoléon
quel dialogue époustouflant du style
pointe alors échangé
sa
savane oui certes napoléon et louis
armstrong n'était pas du même milieu
armstrong n'avait même pas son certif
alors peut-être n'aurait-il jamais
sympathisé enfin on peut rêver alors
rêvons dans un sens
c'est
au moins de
cinq ans tel rythme
étonnant non
de nos jours on ne peut plus vivre sans
parler l'anglais
c'est en tout cas ce que tout le monde
prétend et bien moi je dis que cela
reste à prouver
regardez bien
[Musique]
m
mais
je ne crois pas ce que me dit cette
personne je ne parle pas l'anglais
s'est de m
et
eh bien oui comme vous venez de le
constater de visu on peut très bien
vivre en ne parlant que le français
alors que comme cette pauvre femme on
peut mourir en parlant anglais
d'ici la fin des haricots
et toning note
[Applaudissements]
de nombreux indécis il me demande ce qu
est un ornithologue
c'est pourtant simple comme son nom
l'indiqué l'ornithologue est une
personne qui étudie les ornitho
caisse 15h nito j'en connais un rayon
attention les enfants ont dit un jour ni
talent des ornithologues
principaux ornitho sont
la fauvette
le flamand fourbe
l'hirondelle outré le coup groupe coucou
le colibri fouille merde il rossignol
l'ornithologue reconnaît un or ni talent
rien qu'à son chant
fauvettes
colibri oui merde
seriez-vous assez aimable pour répéter
hirondelles outre et
rechignent up joueurs du fond du
ruisseau 6 nov
non non
[Musique]
de nombreuses un b s'il me demande
pourquoi jeanne d'arc était surnommée la
pucelle d'orléans
et bien c'est très simple jeanne d'arc
était surnommée la pucelle d'orléans
pour deux raisons essentielles 1 l et es
d'orléans 2 elle était plus elle est
elle le resta jusqu'au bout comme en
témoigne le rapport du médecin légiste
après l'autopsié
je suis formel mais direz-vous pourquoi
cette jeune fille qui était belle
courageuse bien foutu catholique
pourquoi jeanne mauritel pucelle et bien
pour le savoir c'est très simple il nous
suffit de nous rapporter 550 deux ans et
demi en arrière dans ses longs doigts
zèle jeune je ma part je garde la
connerie à ma soeur josette
je suis josette d'arc n'empêche que
c'est pas pour me vanter mais pendant
qu'elle garde ma que nous il ma soeur
jeanne ne livre pas son corps d'albâtre
à deville attouchements que la morale
réprouve en dehors des liens sacrés du
mariage
étonnant non
[Musique]
aujourd'hui pour tuer le temps en
attendant la mort nous allons jouer à un
jeu culturel et amusant j'ai près de moi
un homme
cet homme est un artiste un un immense
artiste
qui s
à vous de découvrir
grâce à lundi ce qu'il va vous donner
lui-même je ne suis pas mort à sainte
hélène
voilà qui devrait vous mettre sur la
voie j'attends vos appels
ah non madame ce n'est pas napoléon
non monsieur ce n'est pas bonaparte
oui
oui oui madame oui madame vous avez
gagné
en effet cher ami cet homme n'est pas
mort à sainte hélène il a l'oreille
coupée et il est fou c'est donc bien van
gogh et il le prouve
vous tenez en eau
[Musique]
chacun ses cousins de la pomme de terre
est un légume sacré c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi les indiens sont en général
moins gras que les bavarois qui compte
n'a pas vu une fois dans sa vie les
spectacles envoûtants les charmeurs de
pommes de terre de la place léon blum de
calcutta ne connaît rien à la magie de
l'inde
regardez bien
[Musique]
coucher
je tiens à préciser que je suis
également charmeur de bureau
étonnant
de nombreux français moyens ont un
préjugé défavorable à l'égard des nazis
sans vouloir faire de l'anti nazisme
primaire je dois dire que je donnerai
pas ma fille à un militant du parti
national-socialiste
et encore on n'a pas tout dit sur les
horreurs et les atrocités commises par
ces gens là
prenez hitler par exemple qu'est ce que
j'ai vu et bien savez-vous que non
seulement hitler était nazi mais en plus
quand ils étaient en vacances
les pipis dans la mer bah oui
personne n'est parfait
[Musique]
et tony annan
aujourd'hui encore les ennemis de
l'amitié franco britannique continue
effrontément d'entretenir cette stupide
légende selon laquelle jeanne d'arc
aurait été brûlée vive à rouen par les
anglais c'est grotesque
c'est grotesque
en effet jeanne d'arc est bien morte
brûlée vive mais c'était un accident et
cela s'est passé à la garenne colombes
et je le prouve
jeanne
jeanne lève toi
l'ennemi est à la porte
[Musique]
quand faut y aller faut y aller
au chlore
étonnant non
[Musique]
plus bon que le héron est moins con que
la cigogne le bergers landais gracile et
haut perchée n'est pas peu fier de sa
situation élevée dans l'échelle sociale
je ne suis pas peu fier de ma situation
élevée dans l'échelle sociale
on
ne saurait en dire autant du mendiant
landais
du balayeur landais
et surtout du malheureux jardinier
landais qui risque sa vie chaque fois
qu'il essaie de planter les choux à la
mode de chez nous
etonnant non
nous allons commémorer ce soir ensemble
le centenaire de la mort du grand savant
français jean-pierre des morales
comme vous le savez de même que louis
pasteur inventa la pasteurisation
jean-pierre des morales inventa la
démoralisation
et je dis bravo
jean-pierre des moral commence à un
blement ses expériences sur sa logeuse
madame brochard qu'il démoralise à le 12
septembre 1847
mais bon
ça va pas durer
je suis démoralisé
encouragé par ce premier résultat moins
d'un an plus tard il démoralise à le
sous préfet de l'isère
il fait beau aujourd'hui
ça va pas durer
demeurant lisez au sommet de sa carrière
jean-pierre des morales réussit même à
démoraliser le dernier tsar de toutes
les russies
nicolas 2
il fait le bon ordre ne va pas durer
tellement khalil et
seul ombre
à sa gloire jean-pierre des morales ne
parvint jamais à démoraliser l'escargot
de bourgogne
il va pleuvoir ça m'est égal
les autres escargots nous adorons la
pluie
je suis démoralisé
etonnant non
[Musique]
nous commémorons cette année avec joie
la mort de deux grands savants français
louis pasteur qui inventa la rage
et marie curie qui inventa la contagion
[Applaudissements]
cela tout le monde le sait
mais ce qu'on sait moins c'est que louis
pasteur et marie curie était très intime
au point que
quand pasteur contrainte à la rage
marie curie la contractent a aussi
mais pas de la même façon
regardez
[Musique]
la rage
eh bien oui vous avez compris comme le
prouve à l'évidence ce document
extraordinaire
marie curie avait la rage dehors alors
que pasteur avait la rage de dents
etonnant non
bien qu'ils ne soient pas tous des
imbéciles les chercheurs scientifiques
ont beaucoup de mal à isoler le virus de
la peste jeux dessus pourtant pas un
imbécile
pourquoi est ce si difficile
et bien pour le savoir voyons ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur d'une goutte de sang
d'un employé aux écritures de
marnes-la-coquette dans le 93 atteints
de la peste bubonique
sur cette image qui nous voyons très
nettement les globules rouges et le
virus de la peste
eh bien oui vous avez compris
s'il est si difficile d'isoler le virus
de la peste
c'est que le virus de la peste ne
supporte pas la solitude
je ne supporte pas la solitude
etonnant non
[Musique]
saint françois d'assise était il aussi
cruel que néron et bien c'est la
question qui est évidemment sur toutes
les lèvres à quelques semaines de la
saint françois ça va être ma fête et à
huit jours de la st néron ça va être ma
fête et bien contrairement à ce que
croit la majorité des gens qui ne sont
pas l'élite sinon par définition il ne
serait pas la majorité des gens et bien
dis-je c'est françois d'assise qui était
le plus cruel des deux et je le prouve
alors que néron se contentait d'envoyer
les chrétiens aux lions françois
d'assise lui faisait pire ils envoyaient
les lions chrétiens
[Musique]
etonnant non
bouleversé par l'émouvant hommage que
nous avons rendu ici même à louis
pasteur le génial inventeur de la rage
ces lois
de nombreux sous doués me demande en
quoi consiste exactement la
pasteurisation à laquelle le regretté
loulou donna son nom la pasteurisation
consiste à porter des aliments à une
température de 75 à 85 degrés
centigrades pour tuer les microbes sans
altérer le goût des aliments
et sans faire chier les vitamines se
pense aux cieux comme vous le voyez on
peut même pasteurisé des fonctionnaires
assermentés
[Applaudissements]
le point blanc
c'est là qu'ils aient toutes les
vitamines
etonnant non
j'ai ici une lettre de madame josette
tous à berlin de verdun qui me demande
je cite comment va le général gamelin au
fait comment vais-je je tiens à le
préciser à l'intention des jeunes
d'aujourd'hui dont les connaissances en
histoire de france englobe toute la
période allant d'hyères soir à demain
matin le général gamelin et s est habile
stratège qui commanda les forces
françaises de septembre 39 à mai 40
fastoche
hélas chère madame tous à berlin le
général gamelin n'est plus il est mort
dans son lit il ya 25 ans
mais alors direz vous comment se fait-il
qu'un si vaillant soldat soit mort dans
son lit
et bien c'est simple regardez bien
je n'ai rien contre les moribonds mais
cette agonie m'insupporte
bon et bien puisque je dérange je vais
aller mourir ailleurs
bien oui je lave ou si le général
gamelin est mort dans son lit si parce
que je n'ai pas voulu qu'il meure dans
le mien
etonnant non
[Musique]
à la guerre tout le monde déguste
mais celui qui dégustent le plus c'est
évidemment le dégustateur d'obus
qu'est-ce que je déguste nous devons
admiré et respecté le valeureux
dégustateurs d'obus grâce à lui quand
arrivera la troisième guerre mondiale la
semaine prochaine si tout va bien nous
saurons mettre un nom sur la mitraille
qui nous déchire 4 à
on dit
toujours
ne sent pas
saint-émilion 66
etonnant non
[Musique]
cet obsédé mexicano film madame josette
volet muchacho me demande quelle est
l'origine exacte de l'hymne mexicain le
fameux vamos a quant à elle dit mme blum
je suis une obsédée mexicano fils le
mexique mexique le mexique mexico
mexique ce
qui est beaucoup l'amérique du sud
pour en savoir plus il nous suffit de
nous reporter cent cinquante ans en
arrière à la fameuse foire aux cactus de
mexico
je me trouve à la fois aux cactus co2
mexico près d'alonso le vieux potier
buriné par trente années de tequila
l'uriné par trente années qu'il est bien
c'est à lui alonso que nous devons
l'hymne national mexicain que lui même
inspiré je
fête de la poterie le jour de foire est
arrivé
en fait de la poterie
les yachts des fois
il est
étonnant tournon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un quarteron de bigote inassouvi me
demande qui de saint vincent de paul ou
de saint martin était le plus
charitables aucun doute n'est permis
c'est saint vincent de paul qui fait
premiers au hit parade de la sainteté
certes le geste de saint martin fut
grandiose
mais saint-vincent-de-paul a fait
beaucoup plus que de donner la moitié de
son manteau un pauvre
regardez bien
[Musique]
il a donné la moitié de son pauvre à la
science sait peu de choses maintenant
non
[Musique]
de nombreux sous doués boursouflé
d'inculture me demande pourquoi la vénus
de milo et le petit prince de
saint-exupéry étaient fâchés à mort
c'est simple
revoyons les faits
la vénus de milo avait mauvais caractère
j'ai pas de bras c'est pas le pied le
petit prince lui était un fort bel
enfant aux grands yeux émerveillés par
la beauté des choses je suis un fort bel
la beauté des trucs des choses
la rencontre du petit prince et de la
vénus de milo dégénéra très vite en
drame
regardez
comment tu t'appelles je suis la vénus
de milo salut vénus de milo bonjour
petit prince
s'il te plaît dessine moi un mouton
c'est mal un petit con
etonnant non
voilà plusieurs siècles que les plus
éminents égyptologue du monde se
demandent en vain pourquoi les anciens
égyptiens marchait toujours de profil
alors que mon beau frère jean louis
marche droit comme le montrent à
l'évidence ce document extraordinaire
film et hier soir 14 rue caulaincourt à
vierzon regardez
extraordinaire
observons maintenant l'ancienne reine
d'égypte madame néfertiti revenant du
marché aux esclaves de pyramides les
bains n'est tel point grotesque ne prête
à tel point tahrir
je prête à rire
mais pourquoi madame néfertiti une
marche tel de profils direz vous bien
c'est simple regardez bien
[Musique]
eh bien oui vous avez compris
si les anciens égyptiens étaient tordus
c'est que quatorze siècles avant
jésus-christ déjà les architectes
étaient tous des cons
etonnant non
[Musique]
une groupie du jésus ce fan club me
demande s'il est exact que jésus-christ
était plus fort que superman
hélas non girveau pis
certes jésus-christ multipliait les
pains dans le désert mais superman lui
multiplié les pains dans la gueule c'est
mieux
regardez bien
[Musique]
or vire jeu catherine que ça fait du
bien quand ça s'arrête
seul super un des formateurs contre leur
colère
et tout le monde
[Musique]
on peut diviser l'humanité en deux
grandes catégories les juifs et les
antisémites je suis le juif je suis
l'antisémite heures de nos jours afin de
d'éviter d'être ridicule en société il
est très important que les antisémites
apprennent à lutter contre
l'antisémitisme
malheureusement ce n'est pas toujours
très simple
regardez
non ce n'est pas simple
à moins d'user d'un habile stratagème
lequel regardez bien
eh bien oui vous avez compris il est
beaucoup plus facile de cacher son juifs
que de cacher son antisémitisme
etonnant non
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est à vous que je
m'adresse chers enfants
savez-vous petit crétin quel âge vous
jouez hobby comme des imbéciles
wolfgang amadeus mozart lui avait déjà
atteint le génie
j'ai toujours été précoce en tant
qu'enfant
savez vous qu'à huit ans et demi mozart
avait déjà composé le boléro de ravel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fastoche savez-vous qu'à 12 ans et demi
accompagné par le quatuor amadeus il
avait déjà déshonoré sa cousine la
petite que celle 506
fastoche mais savez-vous qu'il était
tellement précoce mozart qu'à 34 ans et
demi il était déjà mort
fastoche
etonnant non
[Musique]
nous commémorons cette année le 40e
anniversaire de la disparition d'antoine
de saint-exupéry
saint-exupéry
l'aéropostale
courrier sud
le vol du bourdon
ces mots provoque-t-il encore quelques
mois dans le coeur d abuser de la
jeunesse frivole de ces temps décadent
être homme disait saint-ex c'est être
responsable c'est sentir en posant sa
pierre
qu'on contribue à bâtir le monde
n'oublions jamais cet homme et revoyons
une ultime fois ensemble ce document
extraordinaire qui nous montre
saint-exupéry après son atterrissage à
rio de janeiro
où malgré tous les dangers et par tous
les temps il fallait que le courrier
arrive à
et une lettre recommandée pour madame
bouchard
avec accusé de réception il faut signer
là y est tout est en règle n'était pas
éclairé ça fait rien dessine moi un
mouton
etonnant non
[Musique]
qui d'entre vous n'a pas été mordu au
moins une fois dans sa vie par un
fonctionnaire sauvage on allons remplir
le formulaire ses 112 de la salle 23 du
bureau des formulaires de bureau
mais c'est pas le formulaire ses 112 je
vous avais demandé de remplir le
formulaire 612 enfin
pour éviter le drame le plus simple est
de tenter d'apprivoiser le fonctionnaire
sauvage et ce n'est pas évident
[Applaudissements]
rien à faire
non pour apprivoiser un fonctionnaire
sauvage il n'existe aucun moyen
c'est la méthode charentaise
regardez bien
[Applaudissements]
je suis apprivoiser etonnant non
[Musique]
le premier imbécile venu témoin le
deuxième a baissé il venu c'est moi et
même le dernier des imbéciles
ces moyens sont parfaitement capables à
force de concentration de regarder la
télévision assis sur une chaise sans
tomber mais dès qu'on enlève la fais
tous les imbéciles ont l'air d'un con
pour bien mesurer l'effort qu'il en
coûte pour rester assis sur rien nous
allons assister maintenant en direct au
congrès annuel des regardeurs de télé
sanchez
rae
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un étonnant non
de nombreuses princesses là c'est de
livrer leurs corps d'albâtre aux
attouchements approximatif de tristes
dauphin dégénéré échangerait volontiers
leur prince charmant contre un plombier
charmant le plombier charmant est en
effet beaucoup plus virile quoique
légèrement plus salissant que le prince
charmant lassé de livrer mon corps
d'albâtre aux attouchements
approximatif un triste dauphin dégénéré
j'échangerais
volontiers mon prince charmant
entre un plombier cham on comble mairie
quoique légèrement plus salissant mais
direz vous comment faire pour
transformer une grenouille en plombier
charmant et bien c'est simple il suffit
de toucher la grenouille non pas avec
une baguette magique
mais avec une clé de douze magique
comment c'est simple regardez bien
je suis le plombier charmant
qui s'est seulement biais charbon
[Musique]
etonnant non
et
tous les hommes sont frères
même ma belle-soeur
c'est pourquoi les hommes doivent
s'entraider
monsieur ou les biens médias traverser
voyez ce pauvre aveugle
personne ne l'aide à traverser moi même
je n'ai pas que ça à faire alors ce
pauvre aveugle et désemparé pour
quiconque a un coeur n'est ce pas là un
spectacle affligeant
monsieur voulait bien médias traverser
avec plaisir il faut bien s'entraîner
et tonneaux
[Musique]
etonnant non